good evening a mother accused of killing
her own child is now in custody thanks
for joining us here at five i'm denise
valdis and i'm brian loftis that after a
nationwide search issued 24 hours ago as
we learned the identity of the child
victim
the i-team's vanessa murphy here in
studio with more on this story
vanessa denise and bryan police say it
appears seven-year-old liam houstead was
alive in las vegas on may 27th
he was in a hotel here with his mother
but the next day they say
they believe she killed him near a trail
in mountain springs
and left his body there so far this
investigation has taken nearly two weeks
and investigators call the mother's
arrest some sense of closure
this is the mug shot for 35 year old
samantha moreno rodriguez taken
just this morning after she was taken
into custody
at a denver hotel her son's body was
identified yesterday that's
seven-year-old liam houstead police fast
tracked the identification process
after a friend of moreno rodriguez saw
this sketch released by metro
i asked lieutenant ray spencer about
this process which he calls time
consuming and complicated
i'll tell you what i have learned over
the last 10 days is how
many missing children there are
nationally i was inundated
with reports of missing children from
all over the united states and when i
said we had hundreds of tips come in
we were going through all of those
because there are so many
missing children lieutenant spencer says
liam's father who lived with the mother
and child in san jose
contacted police there on june 1st with
concerns but didn't want to get the
mother in trouble
moreno rodriguez had left him sort of a
dear john message on may 24th
saying she was sorry and she was going
to try to get a house to live with liam
and she had taken their belongings but
again police connected the dots after
the friend reached out on june 4
about the sketch police have not
released
the cause of death for liam no word on a
motive yet either but we know detectives
are currently
interviewing moreno rodriguez back to
you
vanessa thanks for that so let's remind
our viewers of the timeline of events
that have happened here in the last two
weeks
police say that liam and his mother left
san jose on the 24th
then on the 26th they can be placed in
the laguna beach area
and then later that same day in
victorville police telling us that she
stayed in a las vegas hotel on the 27th
but then liam's body was discovered the
next day in mountain springs
then on the 29th marina rodriguez's car
was seen traveling on i-70 near grand
junction
then fast forward to the 31st she
checked herself into a denver area hotel
and that's where we find deborah
takahara live tonight with more on the
arrest deborah
we're at the denver detention center
where samantha moreno rodriguez will be
held until she is taken to las vegas to
face charges
of murder investigators were able to
take her into custody this morning
just before six o'clock this morning
they say she was taken into custody
without
incident and they say they are relieved
she was found and taken into custody
so quickly after releasing that picture
to the media yesterday
still unclear about how investigators
tracked her to that motel
but they say they are here trying to
interview her and they'll get more
information in the days and weeks to
come
live in denver deborah takahara back to
you deborah metro police just talking
about how relieved they are too that she
is now in custody
any idea of how long it might take for
her to come back to las vegas
well they say if she agrees to waive
extradition she could be back in vegas
by the end of this week
but they say if she decides to fight
extradition it could take up to 30 days
now deborah there were several days
there that we really haven't quite
figured out where she was
but today when she was finally taken
into custody was she alone was there
anybody with her
we do understand from investigators they
tell us she was with an unidentified man
they won't tell us much about him
although they do say they do not believe
they are confident he was not involved
in liam's death
or any way involved in this case deborah
takahara reporting live tonight in
denver thanks for that